This is an interesting story that I thought
I'd bring up with you today.
There's been a debate recently over the claim
that Elizabeth Warren predicted the 2008 financial
crisis before it happened and most of the
focus on the story has been on the wrong thing.
Most of the focus has been on determining
did Elizabeth Warren predict the financial
crisis or did she not actually predict the
financial crisis?
But I don't actually think that that's the
right argument at all to be having.
I'll tell you the facts first and then I'll
tell you why.
I think the entire conversation is being framed
incorrectly.
2020 Democratic candidate Elizabeth Warren
did a CNN town hall and one of the things
that she said was that she predicted the 2008
financial crisis.
She said, quote and starting in the early
two thousands the crisis was coming.
I was waving my arms, ringing the bell, doing
everything I could.
I said, families are getting cheated all over
this country.
It started when the mortgage companies targeted
communities of color.
They targeted seniors, they targeted Latinos.
They came in and sold the worst possible mortgages
and stripped wealth out of those communities
and then took those products across the nation.
I went everywhere I could.
I talked to about it to anyone who would listen.
A crisis is coming.
So is this true that she did this?
Basically it is.
Okay.
Before 2008 Elizabeth Warren was talking about
the impending housing and financial crisis
in her 2003 book.
She talked about it, subprime lending and
housing crisis in 2004 on PBS.
She said that the growing household debt,
the growing number of risky mortgage lending
practices are causing a problem.
In 2005 she told the New York Times that the
amount of home equity debt that homeowners
were getting into was a big red flag.
And politifact looked at this and determined,
yes, Elizabeth Warren did predict the financial
crisis.
But here's my reaction.
So what Elizabeth Warren did predict the financial
crisis, but why is that a big deal?
Tons of people predicted it.
Tons are predicting another crisis now and
none of it is even remotely notable, requires
special insight to predict.
W what I mean by that is obviously our economic
system and circumstances are not sustainable.
Of course, there's always a financial crisis
or a major downturn somewhere on the horizon.
The question is, is it a year away or four
years away or eight years away?
I don't know how notable it is that Elizabeth
Warren predicted something that anyone who
understands the boom and bust cycles of our
economic system has been predicting.
As a matter of fact, for decades, uh, or for
as long as they have been following the economy,
these boom bust cycles are implicit and inherent
to the economic system that we have.
They're always on the horizon.
The question is just when, so one of the reactions
to this entire Elizabeth Warren thing has
been, well, we would care about whether she
did or didn't predict it because we should
want a president who has the foresight to
predict when the next crisis will be.
Well, okay.
That may be, but anybody who understands how
the economy works should understand that there's
always a looming crisis on the horizon.
There's always a looming downturn on the horizon
because it's implicit to the system.
We have the vulture capitalists cycles of
boom and bust that increase inequality and
increased despair don't happen less frequently
unless we actually deal with the problems
inherent to the system that we have.
So Elizabeth Warren predicted it, tons of
people predicted it, and anybody who understands
our system understands that such a crisis
is always on the horizon.
It's great that Elizabeth Warren is actually
talking about it, but having the foresight
to predict it is actually not notable, although
I'm glad that it is getting more attention.